hello
everybody and thank you so much for
coming to the janus talk my name is issa
i go by they and she pronouns i'm
curious um clearly you read the talk
description and hate it if you're here
how many of you checked out the website
nobody okay so you're probably wondering
what on earth janus is and also how many
of you um write front end code is kind
of like part of your lives like you're
kind of comfortable with it okay great
cool so um i
had a lot of trouble trying to figure
out how to summarize janus for you in
like one scientific pithy description
um
and that meant just i had a lot of
trouble like starting this slide deck at
all
um and so rather than try to give you
any kind of like
clean description of janus why don't we
start with three glimpses and an apology
here's our first glimpse these are all
of the
exports um that are in janus this is the
top level stuff that comes out if you
just require janus you can see there's
some nested stuff those are still top
level requires they're just you know for
example all this stuff on our model just
helps you deal with models and describe
what a model is um so you can see all
the way on the left i'm sorry the font
size does seem to be a little small
you
have some core data flow components you
have some data structures in the middle
here that should look pretty familiar
sets and lists and maps and models
over here we have a view and a dom view
so janus isn't specific to a web browser
so the dom view is our our web browser
viewing
and we have some templating features
there and we have an application uh sort
of glue code stuff that
we won't talk about much today but they
just provide context for your entire
application and you can learn more on
the website so that's kind of like a 10
000 foot view let's look at some code
so here's everybody's very favorite
first friend and framework example it's
a task list
and you can see i can come here i can
create new items
i can fill them in with text i can
check these boxes all the stuff updates
and let's just see how this works right
so over here we have just our model code
and all we're doing is um just defining
some basic schema information here right
done as a boolean name as a text
and we also have um this checklist and
the checklist we just declare a model we
don't even give any implementation so
apparently that's all we need to do so
that's the task and then the checklist
is the whole thing right and so let's
look at the view code so the view code
is what's drawing the stuff along with
of course some css that you're not
seeing
the task view it looks like we have this
snippet of html we have the done and it
looks like we render the attribute done
into there which must have something to
do with this attribute done up here same
with the name this name up here
and then when you click on the button it
looks like we get an instance of the
task itself
and all we do with it is we just destroy
it interesting
let's look at the checklist view the
checklist view is this whole box
together
and it's kind of the same thing in a way
you have this whatever of whatever
complete text which through the magic of
css ends up on the bottom
you have this list which is just a list
of tasks themselves so it's going to be
the list of these task views and you
have a new button and so the way you
wire that up is pretty similar we're
rendering the the tasks into the list
from tasks
and then let's look at this total count
over here right
we're setting its text from that list of
tasks and we're flat mapping it for some
reason um that's kind of strange but the
key part is here for the tasks we want
to get the task length which makes sense
however many tasks are in that array the
length of that array is what we want to
put here right
similarly with the
done count here you can see that it's
almost the exact same thing we're just
filtering down that task list by whether
the task itself is done or not which we
already have a boolean for
and then we count the length of that
and so that's how this stuff updates
and um down at the bottom here we just
have this button and when you click on
it
we again get an instance of the
checklist this time and when we get
tasks out of it
and we have an underscore here for some
reason that's very interesting and when
we get the tasks out of it we just want
to add a new task
finally we have this glue code over here
with the app
the there's a standard library which we
kind of teach the app about and that
just lets the app know how to render
things like check boxes and text boxes
because we didn't do anything with that
right
we also then teach the app views hey if
you want to draw a task you want to use
a task view if you want to draw a
checklist you want to use a checklist
view and from there all we have to do is
just create our data we make a new
checklist we create a new list of tasks
and we ask the app to draw it
and notice what you don't see here you
don't see any handling code you don't
see any reaction code you kind of just
see kind of a seamless blend of timeless
binding code
and timeful data
manipulation code that really just
speaks very simply about what the data
task is that you want to do right
and you might wonder yourself okay how
does this actually work and i could show
you i could come here and i could delve
into here i could show you how this dom
view is actually composed of these
bindings just like we set up we could
look at this two count and we could see
how it's actually doing that filter that
we just described on the left we can
look at this filtered list and look
inspect into it and actually see how the
original list is actually being mapped
by these functions into this current
result i could even go further and show
you how this entire slide deck
is actually
being driven
by
the list of slides agglomerated across
all of these sections
than just being looked up by this active
index right and that that's right here
that's this computation you can see the
history that we've gone through these
three slides
um but maybe that's a little
overwhelming right now and uh maybe i
should
step back go to the next slide and turn
the causal off again
and it looks like it's time for my
apology i am
so sorry i'm here presenting a
javascript front-end framework to you in
year 2021. um
i am so sorry we've all used so many
even if you just look at like the big
two we've all used so many right um and
in my defense this was started in 2013
which kind of leads to my other apology
i'm kind of out of date i code reviewed
some react and view apps but i don't
really know deeply how they work and
also i'm really not
and have not been for a while a
full-time coder i'm really more of a
designer and so i don't have that
mathematical brain so if you come and
ask me like does this have applicative
functors is it monetic algebraic i don't
know these things um i can tell you i
looked at them and tried to incorporate
those ideas um but
i don't have that kind of brain and
again that's kind of why it was kind of
difficult for me
to figure out how to describe to you
like
in a sentence what is janus like how how
does it feel in a sentence
um and eventually i realized that
actually i don't want to tell you
anything like that at all i want you to
walk away with three ideas about what
janus is and those are that janus is
ergonomic
thoughtful
and flexible
and so to prove that to you let's look
at some more code
here we have an example taken almost
exactly off the janus homepage
up top i'm going to go through it very
quickly i just really want to get you a
little more brain practice like looking
at janna's code before we move on to
bigger examples
here we have just some animals animal
species that we're creating looks like
each one has a name we're just putting
some extra information in there like
whether it's a mammal we have this pet
it has a name just like our tas did but
this kind is now an enum
so you can have an attribute
and here is how you provide additional
implementation information for like what
is that attribute describe this
attribute
so you can see that the kind can be a
dog a cat or a parrot just like we've
described up here so any of these model
instances are valid values for this kind
the pet editor down here you can see it
just draws each of these lines it looks
very similar to the task list you just
saw the only difference is we have this
options which stringifies the name and
of course you know these these select
boxes aren't going to be very happy to
take animals they want strings and so
the stringify is kind of just how we
make that happy
then we just make a bunch of our data
and whoops
and um we draw each of these editor
lines over here and down here what i'm
doing is i'm just filtering down by all
the dog names and so you can see um
we we start with the pets we just filter
down by pet kind as a dog and then we
grab the name out of it and that's
what's showing up over here and so once
again what i kind of want to take you
away what i want you to take away from
this is um i can come here and update
any of this information on the way like
this dog that i've exposed and you can
see dog becomes pup over here right i
can update these names i can update all
the stuff and without really having to
set anything up like that it all just
works
cool
let's look at just a slightly bigger
example
this doesn't have very much new stuff in
it i kind of just want to show you what
janus looks like when you're dealing
with like bigger more like real world
applications with just like a bunch of
croft in them right here's a credit card
processing form
and it's not complete there's no
validation i don't have time to talk
about model validation in janus today
it's also driven by data binding but you
can see i can you know fill out this
credit card form and it'll tell me what
credit card i'm using um and i can tell
tell it i'm at you know or is this 12 80
or 1820 i can't remember
and i can ship my stickers to a
different address i don't want so it's
pretty standard stuff
um and a lot of this is stuff you've
seen before in fact all of this is just
attributes and enums and things
here we can nest models and models which
makes sense and the main reason you want
to teach janus about this is so that you
can you can just handle your data when
serializing and do serializing and other
kinds of tasks
you have the address view down here
which again verbatim from the task list
right no reason to change anything about
that on the right is where you have some
new things
janus is a model view view model
framework we really believe that models
are great at handling data and views are
really really great at binding that
model data onto the screen and just
directly interacting with you know
telling the model what it means what
needs to happen the one case where you
kind of run into trouble with this very
sort of like tight binding world is
sometimes you just have computation or
data that isn't model information that
your view still needs and so view models
are a very convenient way to do that
janus allows you to declare a viewmodel
class for any view so every view has a
subject a single subject as you may have
gathered we can also associate a view
model with it and the the dom view will
just spin one up and basically bind the
subject and the view model against each
other with context and so
let's take a look at how that actually
works
you can see there's um this different
address checkbox here this is an example
of like data that doesn't fit in the
model right the payment processor
doesn't care if the user checked this
checkbox or not they just want to get
the payment and shipping address and so
we put that boolean in the view model so
it just never shows up in the model at
all it's a view concern
we also do some computation here so
we're figuring out what credit card
they're paying with in the view model
just to kind of keep that clear and
maybe if we need to use it in a couple
other places this is a convenient way to
kind of like store that computation
somewhere and so you can see from this
time we're saying from dot subject and
so that's how from the view model you're
saying like hey actually i want the
context on the subject get me things
from over there and we want the credit
card number
and using that we just do this like
truly awful test i wrote just to see
whether you're using visa or mastercard
right
and where does that get used that gets
used down here in this new mutator have
you haven't seen before which is class
group class group is kind of like you
know just jquery setting a class you can
for example down here active is just
based on that checkbox and you can see
this is from.vm um just like
from.subject up above reference the the
subject if you're in the in the dom view
you can reference the view mode by doing
from.vm right and that's how this line
fades in and out is just that class
but this class group here basically just
ensures that no matter what value of
this is there will always be network
that as a class so the the class on on
somewhere in here will always be network
visa network dash mastercard or network
unknown and i want to just like show you
a little bit about how janus handles
that
if i can get the console to show up
so i can look at
yes
um
and here's all that and here's that
class group right and so we can look at
how that computation happens
and i can just start messing with this
so i can type some stuff in and you can
see right now it's unknown um and as i
type in 5 1 2 3
you just have
all of these changes that didn't
actually do anything but we're still
seeing them and this highlights two
things one janus won't update things
that doesn't have to and two when you're
using these debug tools
even stuff that didn't affect the value
if it could have you'll know about it
and this is i i have found really
crucial for some of these like frp type
things where the data flows sometimes
end up like locked away from you or or
the code gets kind of like entered and
exited so many times it's just difficult
to like debug the thing that you want
this way you get all this history and
you can see it
all right um the
last thing i want to show you on this
page oh i guess up here um
every time you check the box we're just
doing a little bit of work to just
duplicate the shipping address back uh
the building address back on the
shipping address so that's how that
works
and we are using this shadowing model
shadowing feature to copy the values
again i don't have time to talk about
that you can check out the website for
more
now one thing you might be wondering
look at this code is like issa this is
like just so repetitive there's all this
boilerplate here can't we cut down on
that some and my response is i actually
really love repetitive boilerplate um
but if you want to do that janus is very
careful to allow a lot of different
styles and flexibility and composition
and so i want to just look at the same
sample but just highlight a couple
things change a couple things and
highlight those lines so you can see
over here instead of finding street and
rendering from attribute street and
doing the same thing for city we're just
making that data and we just may have
this helper function that then calls
find and plugs those things in
right and the key information here is
that find is perfectly happy not to live
inside of template
and in fact in this right side we take
it even further we take exactly the same
helper function break it out of
everything entirely
and then down here
we use it
against this array instead and so that
cut down on all of those lines um and so
you can all of these primitives in janus
are
free you're free to use them in any way
assemble them in any way and you'll see
over the course of this talk that while
you're using janus you are actually
using the primitives of janus more or
less you're never very far from the bare
metal
here's another style of composition you
can do you can include templates and
other templates
and so i can have this as something that
exists somewhere else i can even name
templates in situ
if this is really where i want to
declare the stuff but i also want to use
it elsewhere i can name it in situ and
reference it back out of the view later
you can find more about that on the
website
so that's sort of like a
sort of bigger maybe more practical
example let's change gears a little bit
this is a tabbed text editor very simple
you can make some tabs
you can name each document you can put
some text in each document that's about
it i just want to show you how this
works
the document again stuff you've seen
before it's got a title and some content
the editor is the whole thing um it
hosts the documents and so you can see
um we have this initial set of documents
which is just a list of a single
document just so we start with one
and then we have this active document
and there's an enum just like you've
seen before right so the the active
document that we are currently looking
at that is highlighted on the tab um
that is uh an enum here and the initial
values that we want to plug in there
comes from well the first item on the
list and here we see this underscore
again and that's a good time to talk
about that
most things in janus if they return
values will give you some sort of a live
result and for most singular values
that's an abstraction we have called
varying they're kind of like mutable
properties from reactive coco have you
ever used that
but really they're their own thing that
that manage things in their own way and
were created just for janus i can't
really describe to you how they relate
to other kinds of frp abstractions other
than i do think it's monadic
and the way you communicate with janice
that actually i want a point in time
result usually is to add an underscore
after it so that's kind of our
convention through everything if you
want to do something timelessly you just
call it if you want to do something time
fully you add an underscore
and so that lets you very seamlessly
just express okay actually right now i
want to get the first document and that
should be initially the the value
whenever you ask for it right and the
values in the editor are just from
documents i could go through all the
work of reference in the model and get
the documents out of it but we have this
beautiful from utility that's
context-free and we can just say from
documents right
um the document view very
straightforward the only thing new here
is that when we draw this down this text
editor down here we're providing this
extra information to the app when the
app is trying to draw this view for us
we're telling it actually find me
something that will draw with like a
multi-line layout and so that's how we
get this text editor this text area here
and so that's something that we the app
knows about and has been told about and
you'll see a little bit more in a second
we have this tab view so that's each of
these tabs up here we would literally
draw a tab tab and just stick the text
in it
and below that we have this editor view
um so that's this whole thing here
we'll start from the bottom actually
because this stuff you've seen before
right we're just rendering from the
active document and you'll notice this
difference between like from and dot
attribute and from right when you do
from active document that's giving you
the actual value when you do
from.attribute it's giving you the ins
this literal instance of attribute.enum
that you've defined here and that just
again like gives you gives the editor
the context it needs to like display the
right values and do the right behaviors
for your attribute right
and so we'll render an active document
from the app document down here and
that's how you get the main view when
you click on a button as you've seen
before we get the document listed at
anyone
the tabs are the thing i kind of want to
show you here we're rendering from the
attribute active document right and so
literally we're asking jan is i want to
pick between documents
that's exactly what i want to do
and how do we want to do that well we
give it again this criteria um and this
time we're doing a style list and that's
we're not getting a drop down this time
we're getting this list style where
actually it just draws all the things
and can click on one to pick it right
and the only thing we're doing is we're
saying actually instead of drawing them
normally draw them with the context of
tab
where does that come into play well down
here when we're teaching the app what to
draw we're saying that document if you
need to draw a document you can do it
with a tab view if i ask for a tab
and this view registration i'm not going
to get too deep into it but this
indirection is really crucial for some
features of janice i also don't have
time to talk about today like server
client seamless rendering janus has the
ability to render markup on the server
pick it back up on the client and make
it interactive
without any re-rendering and with one
set of code
and a big part of letting this happen is
to still account for differences that do
exist in the environments right so for
example on janus documentation website i
don't have any interest in creating all
these code mirror instances and
formulating them down to html and
sending them to a client
to try to make them work right i just
put the code on the screen
and so
and then on on the client version
instead i uh draw the code mirror editor
and so i just register a different view
for that exact same model in these
different cases right and then in that
one case i do have to account for
redrawing it
and this applies not just to views but
also remote network resources you can
bind remote network resources directly
to model attributes back onto model
attributes and moreover because we don't
have promises we have varyings you can
refulfill a varying as many times as you
want the very first commercial
application that ever shipped on janus
actually shipped on websockets
which is very interesting
and on the server side they use http to
communicate within our stack to get the
data it needed right so that was kind of
how we manage that and the only thing
you have to do to account for those
environment differences is just register
a different set of resources when you
spin up your app you don't have to
branch around
um so that's one thing i wanted to
highlight the other thing i want to show
you has more to do with the sample
itself and that's how we did these tabs
you know like often if we want to do
tabs we go get like a tab component and
we feed into it like okay here are the
tabs and icons maybe and here's like
event or handler for when you click on
the tab and i'll update the data
up here right we don't do any of that
here we ask for the thing we want we
want to choose between an enum
the power of like the janus sort of
library and the way it maps data on the
screen isn't that we've created like a
massive amazing beautiful library of
components for you actually all the
components we have are really primitive
it's in the ability to express your
ideas in a way that map on the screen
and almost turn problem solving into
data modeling
i want to show you an example that goes
deeper into that here are three boxes
you can drag them around you can see
down below here's just some like working
data debug data that we're exposing just
so you can a little bit see how it's
working but let's talk through it
um we have uh
this workspace we don't even
bother to offer an implementation it's
just the main box
the workspace view we just draw the
workspace and we put the boxes in it
so the box again no implementation but
when we draw a box again we draw a box
and we set the css left to left and top
to top and we just change into percents
so that css is happy
and then finally we on mouse down it
looks like we want to drag within the
workspace so that's with within this box
the left and top properties as x and y
so x and y are kind of configurable
property names on the box model itself
with this drag utility and the reason
for that is because this is actually
copied out of i think the janus
documentation website this is real
working code that i wrote
so let's see how drag works right this
first set of parameters we take
are
very
are just the ones that we supply here
right work workspace left and top and
the second set of parameters we take
relate to the event handler for mouse
down so event is the web browser event
it here is uh the box model and view is
the box view and so we just have that
data to kind of play with and do what we
need i'm not going to go exactly into
depth into every single line here but
in general what we do is we create one
of these drag models which we define up
here
all right
and
we just kind of feed it some basic
information so it can compute with so we
have this container and we just want to
give it that dom view right and so we
have this view navigation stuff which
helps you navigate the view hierarchy
and gives you a little more control into
like context like if you're drawing
interface for a list item sometimes
because janus is so independent um and
kind of decentralized it can be
difficult to get sibling context or get
the parent list context to do something
with it which sometimes you just have to
do in ui and so view navigation lets you
do that
i'm not going to get too into it but uh
you can see there's an underscore here
which should tell you something about
you know what this feature can do for
you if you wanted to right so that's how
we get this dom
and then um the in values are just the
current x and y off of the box model
itself right so that's how we set up
sort of this little model here
we have this at uh method on the drag
model which i'm not going to kind of go
into the implementation of all it does
is read a mouse event and store it at
like a location on the model so for
example we have out dot x out dot y down
here when we call operational at down
with the mouse down event it'll say
down.x dot y is whatever the current
event is right
all right
next um anytime you move your mouse in
the window we want to set the now
right and so now that we've actually set
in and
down and now events um or or data we
actually have everything we need to
compute where the box should be now
right so here's that computation up here
is pretty straightforward and we just
use it once for x and once for y
and by the way this is how you bind
multiple values together in janus in a
single statement right so
you say from in x from down y from now
now x i didn't say that right you just
flat map all those to the calc
same thing with y
and so based on those out values now
down here every time they change we're
just setting the new computed value back
on the original box model
all right um set is curried so that's
why you're only seeing the key here um
but and you might be wondering to
yourself um what is listen to and what
is react to right react is how you kind
of observe a varying over time and and
you definitely know what listen to
listen is but what are these two things
they basically just tie those listens
and reactions to the life cycle of that
model so anytime that model gets
destroyed or cleaned up which happens
right here when we mouse up on the
window
operation.destroy all of this stuff goes
away
right and so that's how this all works
and the thing i kind of want to draw
your attention to is how
models and jannas can almost become
problem solving spaces almost like even
like observable notebooks right there
are these non-linear spaces where you
can just reason about data values you
don't have to order them you don't have
to tightly bind them
and it's very easy to think about and
refactor it's very easy to grow
and and it just frees you from
a lot of the sort of rote maintenance
that usually happens in building these
kind of computations right
let's take that just a little bit
further
um
oh actually i want to say one more thing
um
i i often get the sense in janus that
i'm not really writing objects or code
or components anymore i'm kind of like
building these contraptions i i don't
know how to convey it like i get this
feeling like i'm not writing code i'm
building these little like living
contraptions that are interbound in
these different ways and and have these
different ways that you can poke at them
to spring and spurring them and the the
seamless blend between timeful code and
timeless code you know bound code and
imperative code is i think a big part of
why that happens it's very natural to
express both kinds of things that you
want to do
all right one very last example
i just want to show you here how easy it
is to extend janus almost everything
that's built into janus can be extended
however you like so you can see over
here we have this flyout renderer right
so you've seen render which just renders
the thing you want in a box flyout says
okay well when you hover over this thing
i will render the thing you want in a
fly on that thing and we've implemented
that on the left here and you can see
this is find two this is our own find
that we've just created and it's got
this file mutator on it that we just
created right so let's very quickly take
a little bit of a look at how that works
on the left here we have one more of
these like little sort of like model
machines right um usually when you uh
do a fly out you know if you hover over
the trigger the flyout ship here if you
hover over the flyout it should remain
and so we have two things that we kind
of have to keep track of whether you're
moused over and so from those dom
elements we're just mapping into this is
hovered uh utility which we've we're
building from a janus lib sort of like
bridge utility to events right so every
time the dom element is mouse over uh
the value should be true every time the
mouse the mouse leave event fires change
the value to false we don't even care
about what's an event just what event
happened right a very convenient way to
track like mouse stuff like this
and down here you can see we just have a
little extra stuff for null checking
because flyout won't always be there
now we want the hovering to to we want
to fly out to stick around whether
whichever thing you're hovered over and
so we just look at those values and we
order them
and finally one thing is like it sucks
um to have no wiggle room right and also
you might as well do in css then
when you mouse out right it's nice if
the file hangs around for a second and
you don't lose it immediately so and
this kind of thing can be tricky in like
a really like truth-bound data-bound
world right where everything is the
truth right now and so janus also
provides some some utilities to lie a
little bit manipulate the truth a little
bit so for example the sticky utility
says that anytime you see the value true
come through hang on to it for an extra
250 milliseconds
right notice how we don't have to write
freaking like set timeouts and clear
timeouts and all this crap
right we're just talking about the data
all right the flyout view really just um
positions itself on screen and when it
shows up it does some calculations so
they can position on itself on screen
and a flyout renderer is down here we're
making one of these uh models up here
right here we're just doing in a way
that makes it resource managed um and i
don't have time to talk about the
resource management and lifecycle stuff
in janus it's on the website you can
learn more about it there
but the essence of this is that um when
we draw when we draw this app here and
often i use the app as like the root
view of the entire of any entire janus
application right
there's there's always some root view
and in that root v all just i'll always
just put this fly out list at the bottom
and just render all the fly outs and so
anytime someone wants to add a fly out
shove it in apps an app will go oh gosh
i gotta render a fly out now and it'll
show up right
and so every time we should be active we
add our fly out to the app flyouts list
and anytime we shouldn't we remove
and that's kind of how this works um
but we kind of have like one
weird issue here it's actually not
working
so why don't we take a look at that
um so i can show you this dom view here
and you can see this binding here is
that text that just uh binds the text
that's in the thing but here's um the
actual computation for whether
the flyout should show up and here's the
flyout model itself right so let's look
at the flyout model itself and you can
see that when we hover over this it
turns the hover trigger turns true and
we hover over that even if hover fly out
turns true right and forgive the
position and getting screwed up the
slide scaling screws it up right
but for some reason the hovered any if
you look at the hover any down here
which is ultimately what matters more it
goes from true to null for some reason
what's the deal with that well we can
take a look at this and we can you know
maybe also pin this so we can just
have it down here and this false is um
the the hover trigger and you can see
this
or
is the or we're doing to order together
these two values and the other value
we're getting is always null and in fact
it's never changing
that's strange because i know from up
here that the hover flyout is definitely
working right and so what i can do is i
can say
oh i have a typo here that says flip out
so if i come back here and change this
to fly out
all of that will work
all right so you're definitely wondering
now
how does any of this work
so we'll get into a little bit of it
the first thing i want you to know is
that janus is pretty small and it's very
decentralized it's about 3 500 lines of
coffee script and it's written copy
script because it was starting to 2013
right there's no reason we should import
it at this point
you can see that there's no sort of like
big orchestrator there's no central
manager here the the largest file here
is varying and that's just because it
has all these different sort of like
data combinations and um resource
cleanups and things to handle
all this stuff is really small you can
see i mentioned app provides context for
your entire application is 43 lines
right so it's actually not doing work
it's literally just providing context so
how does all this stuff work janice is
really like a
build a trillion pipelines through
syntax sort of deal so
let's look at one of these from
statements that we've been kind of um
throwing around right we can assign it
into a variable and if i return this
variable it's totally useless janice
doesn't even want to draw it um because
this is all just inert there's there's
nothing here you can't do anything with
this right you have to give it some data
context to work against
and so if i make a data object here like
this model
i take that chain i can then point it at
that data context and you know models
provide a pointer for you which will
point
any from statement against themselves
and then we just have this inspect up
panel down here so that we can see the
result
and uh that
maybe
helps some but not much because what on
earth does data pointer do so let's look
into that um so this is up here is
exactly the same code uh it's just that
we've implemented data pointers
specifically for this context ourselves
so we're saying chain.point and we're
giving our own function we're using this
match thing we do have like kind of
primitive case classes in janus kind of
stolen from scala they're not meant to
be anything like pattern matching or
anything like that it's really just
varyings can store one value and if we
want to store like success or failure
along with that value it helps just wrap
it in something that looks like a case
class and then it also became a nice way
to express extensibility like this you
can you can build extensibility in and
use case cast class matching to actually
like build all those features right map
all those features in when you need to
so here what we're doing is we're
matching each of these from statements
right each of these from components and
we're saying well if i see a dynamic one
and what's dynamic well you remember i
can do like from.vm or from.subject all
these things if i don't provide an
explicit thing that i'm looking for it's
from.dynamic right i don't know what you
mean
and so every time i'm handling a dynamic
from whatever key you gave me inside of
it which can be any parameter it doesn't
care um i just want to go to this data
and get it which will get us a varying
of that value right and that kind of
reifies that computation that gives it
the data context it needs to make this a
real computation bound against a real
data source and you can see that here
two and three and all that
down here i've written all of that again
just kind of broken out and not compiled
through janus right so you can do a
variant.all data.getx data i'll get y
and then map all of that or you could
lift it instead if you want to there's a
number of different ways to do this
stuff
um but what i want you to see is how
this kind of maps together you know
we're doing a dot all dot all we're
doing a data dot get x and that that's
you know this is fulfilling that and the
x is coming from here you know so this
is all just kind of getting assembled
from this very context-free stuff and
the the context is being provided
when we need it
but notice what isn't happening here
anything it's all pure there's there's
no side effects here right in fact janus
is telling us that it's inert there are
no observers and only when we click on
this does does it finally tell us it is
five right so janus does try to be lazy
whenever it can and won't run any
computation it doesn't have to
um
with an exception uh but let's actually
add some side effects to this and
that'll just kind of round out our
little tour into like janus internals
this right here is literally a mutator
from janus it's modeled after the jquery
at your uh you know command
it takes a prop that you want to set it
takes some data where of course in our
case the data can be a value that
changes over time
and so it does stuff with that
and the second thing it takes is just
context right notice the pattern what
you want and then the context and so
here's the dom node that you want to
affect here's the data context and we
have this immediate true thing just
because again remember i mentioned you
can pick up code on the client without
re-rendering it so we do need to be able
to instantiate all this stuff without
doing anything and so that's what
immediate does
don't worry about too much of that right
now you can learn more on the website
let's look at the rest of this though
how it assembles it together we're
taking the data
we're just pointing it we do all just in
case but we're pointing it with the
point that you give us
then we react on it right so here's the
side effects we're reacting on it
finally
um
and uh you know we're passing that
immediate but given the value then we
finally are just using jquery to prop
and to set the prop and safe just make
sure it's a string so everything's happy
right so that is literally an entire
mutator in janus that is like how azure
dom mutation works in janus period
and most of the mutators are pretty much
that simple
you can even use them directly you can
pull them this mutator directly out of
the janus package feed it these first
two parameters and you have this weird
machine that given some sort of dom node
and some sort of pointing target some
sort of contextualization target for
this from chain will
set the id of that dom node to the id of
whatever context you're giving it right
um and in fact this sort of weird setup
right here is not any different than
what dom view itself does
right dom view does no orchestration it
does no management all it does is set
these things up and make sure they're
torn down and cleaned up afterwards and
react by the way um
returns a ticket that lets you tear
things down so
that's how it does that and down here
once again i've just rewritten this just
as like sort of like i guess a compiled
version right we're just getting the
idea we're reacting on it we're setting
all this stuff
um the main thing i want to illustrate
with the janus internal stuff besides
just giving you a little sense of how it
does work is how
again you're really using the primitives
of janus all the time and that means
that if you ever need to do something
that janus doesn't do it's a much more
seamless tail off right it's not like
some of these other ecosystems where the
platform is generic and abstract and
kind of a little impartial and you can
build your own little empires inside of
it right you in janus the the primitives
kind of you can you can continue to pull
on them and bring them into the rest of
your custom faster lightning code
whatever you need to do if you need to
break out of the janus world right it
really eases that transition
but with all this like sort of like
independent pipeline construction you
must be wondering okay fine is this fast
is this fast at all and the answer is
like no it's not as fast right just
inherently as part of the approach
there's a lot
a little more memory pressure there's
just so much stuff we have to handle
um we do take a lot of care to make
things fast right all those selectors
you saw we actually pre-compute them so
by the time they're actually running
against a view they're just simple tree
walks
lightning fast
different things like that but
yeah janice is a little slower part of
that is just because i'm me and you know
i don't have a huge team
and part of that is the approach but
also i wonder if it's the right question
the goal behind janus isn't to make a
beautiful technical achievement and it's
not to build the fastest functional
system ever it's to make ideas easier
safer and more comfortable to express is
to take all of these like features in
these modern web applications where we
have all this interactivity where like
especially when you get into like
creative applications or building these
really complicated management things you
have these interactions that become like
this right and especially like the more
the convenience features the more
different ways to do the same thing the
more like user-friendly things
human-friendly things you want to add it
always does this right to front-end code
and the whole idea behind janus is to
try to pull those things apart a little
bit and clarify the data flows and make
them so much easier to express that we
actually have time we actually have time
to build these more features to make our
software more friendly for our users
and it and make it more maintainable in
the future so we don't dread building
all these features right and i would
argue that in the end of the day that's
faster
it's fine if we render a millisecond or
two faster and sometimes something just
has to run x fast i fully acknowledge
that
but for the most part i think a
friendlier interface will always be a
faster interface because the user gets
some of their life back
there is one exception i mentioned
earlier to this like performance and
laziness
the data structure transformation stuff
is eager right now
i'm not clever enough to figure out how
to make it not and i would love your
help with that we'll talk about that in
a second and folds especially our
nightmare because they're very very easy
mathematically to express in this
framework but pretty tricky to make
performance and so that's another thing
where i could use some help
and that actually gets us really nice
nicely in the next steps for janus right
i've already talked about some moving
out of coffeescript we can get rid of
jquery you've seen it everywhere there's
no real reason we need it other than it
got us off the ground faster right we
can get rid of it and just manipulate
the dom and i'm sure janice will get
faster out of that
but also i haven't felt the need to make
it faster that's part of why it is the
way it is
i've not run into a problem with it so
far
um
and uh you know even in this world like
very decentralized world there's still
data flows that we can kind of analyze
and observe and optimize right and we're
not doing any of that today
what else is next for janus well this
debug tool that you've seen um imagine
this being part of your development
experience in fact it has been part of
mine building the slide deck every time
a sample wouldn't show up or was
misbehaving i could just come in here
and take a look at it right
and it gives you this much quicker way
to delve around and look at what's going
on in your application than i've ever
had before
and now imagine but there's still like
this problem here right like i i'm
building the code i have to rebuild it i
have to reload the deck
once i'm in the deck i have to recreate
the state i'm in that that had the
problem and then i have to go and
inspect and actually like delve through
everything and find it what if um all of
that just worked
and so this is a prototype i worked on a
while ago
for a website i made called apollo 13
real time which actually is run on janus
and this is just to kind of convey that
concept to you
imagine if
you can have this is loading up that
apollo 13 code
off of disk you don't see any of it here
and it's actually live reloading it as
well that's what this little refresh
does here you can turn on and off right
live reload on the left here we're
setting up some state we're loading some
fixture information we're clicking on
some things different stuff like that
and then we just have all this debug
information on right here right so if i
want to like
you know
delve into this a little bit
get some more information i can totally
do that right oops come on
there you go
i can totally do that and this is a view
that can be saved so imagine now you
have all these different views for
states that our application can be in or
problem layers that you're having and
moreover what if we can take this a step
further and say actually what if in this
application state i really like this
value and i could just check a box or
something and say make sure that value
is that it's an assertion right it's a
very simple cheap unit test
and so imagine that
being part of your development
environment that's kind of what's next
for janus i would love your help with it
if you want to do that of course i'm
sure you'd want to check out the website
janusjas.org
it has among other things of course an
api reference but also a practical guide
for people who learn better hands-on and
building things and a first principle
guide for people who really want to
delve into theory and learn how to use
these building blocks
we also do have like a code of conduct
and a discord which is just me
this talk is also available on github if
you want to check it out
all the source code is there you can run
it yourself
it is a little sensitive to the screen
size but hey
i also have one very quick plug for you
i work on a free on open source project
called odk it is a android based mobile
data collection system used pretty much
every year in every country on earth we
miss north korea this year but whatever
we are used by ngos around the world for
everything from
deforestation monitoring species
endangerment disease tracking and
vaccination efforts ring vaccination
other things which as you might imagine
has made the last couple of years
very intense for us
we're almost entirely volunteer run and
one thing i have found in the 10 years
working on this project is that open
source really only works for developer
focused projects there are exceptions
but
man we're i'm
so pleased when i get a contributor a
year
and so um you know red cross for example
is one of our users i don't care about
the red cross i mean i do but if the red
cross wants a problem solved they can
hire someone to do it what i care about
is the the countless tiny shops around
the world using the stuff to solve
problems in their communities because
that is happening every day and those
people depend on your help so if you
could please check it out and consider
learning some of your hours
i'd like to close out just by asking one
more time what is janus
is janus a framework about frp kind of
is janus a framework about timefulness
and timelessness kind of is janus a
framework about
you know all these different things kind
of
but that's not why it is the way it is
in fact if you go back to 2013 when i
first talked about this and you go back
to you know the all the entire history
the source code is online you can see
that a lot of these interface ideas a
lot of these expression ideas were there
they were just expressed they were way
more oop and there are way more other
things just to you know janice has
always been a framework that's tried to
cater to familiarity right try to cater
to the familiarity of
people who are writing code today
already
um and and so it's not any of those
things
janus is the way it is because the goal
was to make it ergonomic thoughtful and
flexible right we arrived at this huge
constellation of primitives because we
wanted to be flexible we arrived at this
binding syntax because we wanted to be
ergonomic
we solve a lot of problems that i didn't
manage to talk about today
and that's kind of the thoughtfulness
and that's what i really hope you take
away from this talk
thank you so much and thank you for
strengthening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you